alright so um welcome back everyone to
the second session this morning and so
Steffie is going to continuous talk on
the competitive analysis of online
algorithms okay so we we've seen the
general the general packing covering
framework it of course the captures
captures many online problems and for
for covering you seen online set cover
we can also do online connectivity cuts
Facility Location paging which we will
see and many many more problems for
packing it's routing matching which we
will see and again many many more many
more problems in we've seen the
algorithm the multiplicative with
multiplicative updates for general
covering yeah for for general covering
and packing and so another another way
of describing of describing the
algorithm which which is a continuous
form is writing a different a
differential equation which describes
the connection between the primal and
the dual variable and since it's an
exponent it's an exponential function
this is the form of the this
differential equation and this is how
they actually they're the exponential
function is it is obtained so let's see
what what kind of
okay what kind of results we can get so
we can get log we can get log D where D
is the maximum row sparsity the maximum
number of variables which are different
with which which are non 0 and 4 for
packing the bounds that we get is a
depends already on the ratio between a
max and amen the maximum and the minimum
entries and the matrix a min is
different is different from 0 and if we
want if we want to get rid of this
we want to get rid of this of this of
this dependency then we have to go back
and change some of the some of the dual
dual variables which in a sense is
equivalent to preemption so that depends
whether we allow the it depends of
course on the context and then they're
in work of an open gupta envision a
garage garage on they showed how to get
a bound for the duel which is which only
depends on the on the sparsity and okay
thanks
yeah okay which general generalizations
can can we talk about so 11
generalization is instead of having a
linear objective function and we have we
have some convex function and this
convex function needs to have some
bounded we need to have some bounded
growth property which is captured by by
this condition of the of the gradient it
turns out that for technical reasons we
also need the gradient to be a treat to
me to be monotone and in this case we
can the competitive bounce that we can
get or given by this expression for
example this captures PP norm p norms
and people have looked at convex
functions minimizing within it with a
convex function it for example in the
context of of energy quite quite quite a
lot and for further for the dual problem
for the maximization problem this
corresponds to two online to two online
auctions online welfare with production
costs and maybe one go back to okay the
duel is now since it's a convex function
the duel is obtained through a central
duel to a dual function or the convict
convex conjugate I won't go into into
the details in this case the update the
update rule is similar to the to the
linear case except that now in the
denominator we have there we have the
gradient and that that gives us the
differential the differential equation
another I'll just quickly talk i'll just
quickly mention another another
generalization is online semi definite
semi definite programming so just i'll
go
so let's look at this yeah it at this
form of semi definite programming so we
have a linear objective function and we
have we have matrices a 1 up to a n with
with a single constraint now this is
bigger than or equal with respect to the
partial order defined by positive semi
definite matrices and this and this is
the dual problem and we and we have weak
duality is very easy to to prove now
what would be that what would be the
online version of this problem well we
can think so we're we have only one one
semi definite constraint but the matrix
B evolves over time and it SAT ever so
everything is positive semi definite and
the matrix BTW satisfies over time BTW
is bigger than or equal to be t minus 1
in the PSD sense and x and y and again
matrix why is PSD and it grows on it
increases in deposit in the PSD in the
PSD sense so how is this related to for
example 2 to set cover so let's look at
let's say this is a set cover instance
we can think about it this way it's a
sum of matrices so this is our set cover
problem and if we look at the matrix
then it's a diagonal matrix where the
diagonal is exactly the characteristic
vector of the of the set and the
left-hand side needs to be bigger than
or equal to 2 a diagonal and all doing
all ones matrix on the on the
I gonna so this is this is set cover in
online set cover this diagonal is being
exposed to us in n steps so instead of
having diagonal matrices we can the semi
definite covering problem is it is a
problem where we replace the diagonal
matrices by PSD by PSD matrices and as
we saw before be evolves evolves online
now yeah in this case it's like you know
all the all possible elements up front
we just don't know which ones need to
become right right but this is also the
version of one of the versions of online
set cover where you get in advance the
set cover instance you just don't know
which elements you will need to do cover
exactly yeah you allow changes in VA
main 8a matrices as well I don't think I
didn't think about it okay if okay you
need to define whether the a matrix can
can contribute to a particular entry and
this is more difficult is a mess to
define in there in the PSD setting so
let me just tell you what is what is the
algorithm so the algorithm is a nice
generalization of online set cover so if
if this constraint is value is is
violated then there is a witness to this
violation which which is a matrix V and
then this violation defines a linear
constraint which is which is not
satisfied well we know how to deal with
that so we we just we just do a a
continuous a continuous update where we
increase the matrix why that's the duel
matrix in the direction of V until this
constraint is satisfied there are
several issues so so this kind of update
a guarantee is a logarithmic logarithmic
competitive factor but the issue is
whether this process will will will
terminate because okay so we we satisfy
a matrix V but then there might be some
other matrix which is not satisfied and
and so on and one observer let me just
go quickly one observation is that if we
yeah the trick is that we go we over
satisfy the constraint and that will
guarantee termination within and at most
n n steps and whether just affect
increased a factor of two in the in the
competitive in the competitive ratio
another
another interesting issue is when you
have box constraints and then there's
you one can define sparsity in an
interesting way but I think I'll I'll
and get a bound in terms of in terms of
this of this notion of sparsity which
generalizes the notion of row sparsity
in the case of set cover but all else
I'll skip that we opened my second
presentation
okay so I want to go over these these
topics let me start with another egg
with another example of of covering
packing which is which is add options so
in add auctions we have these ads on the
side and the way this works is that we
have we have advertisers which set a
daily a daily budget and then we have
and they also provide bids on keywords
that are interested to them let's not
it's not the it's not a game theoretic
issue we just think of it as a number
they're willing to pay for showing their
ad for those those keywords we have a
search engine which needs to select I'd
say one ad per user so user appears he
puts in some this is a very simplistic
model of course if the user puts in some
search word this search maps to a bunch
of advertisers which are interested in
this user and if and each of them if
each of these advertisers if their ad is
going to be shown the adverse I the
advertiser will pay for the the bid on
that the bid that he committed to but
the advertiser also has a daily budget
which cannot be which cannot be exceeded
exceeded so we can think of it this is a
bipartite graph one side is fixed that's
the advertisers or the buyers let's call
them each one has a budget and now we
have the key words or the items they
appear one by one online whenever an
item appears we know which buyers are
interested in that item
and what will be so we are Google
Microsoft whatever we want to maximize
the total the total revenue okay so we
can write this as an LP so y IJ is just
indicator for the Jays Edward going to
the i'th buyer and we want to maximize y
IJ x bij bij is the bid that the ice
buyer had put on the j DH on the JS item
and and of course each item cannot be
sold more than once so sigma YJ is at
most one and the sum of the BI JS is it
most is it most be B of I so we cannot
exceed the budget of an affair of buyer
of of an advertiser and okay
the prime of the covering problem is of
course it's very similar to what we saw
with with the grouting so the constraint
is that for every edge IJ bij x exif iso
exif eyes for a buyer z of JS for an
item so bi bi j times X of I plus Z J is
bigger than or equal to b IJ and this is
our objective function now the natural
algorithm is of course the the greedy
algorithm when an item appears you just
sell it to the buyer which is willing to
pay the maximum value for it as long as
his daily budget hasn't been exhausted
this algorithm is half competitive and
unfortunately it's not more than this is
the worst case I won't show you and
there's a simple simple example what
would be the primal dual algorithm but
pardon
ZJ well it's it's a variable which
corresponds to two an item so the buyers
are indexed by I and their variable each
buyer is associated with a primal
variable X of I and each item is
associated with a primal variable Z J
the problem that we want to solve it I
know it's a bit confusing is the dual
problem it's we want to maximize this
value and we're using these constraints
for that and the for every item J and by
your I where there is an edge between
them with value bij we have this we have
this constraint
so ZJ corresponds to to this to this
constraint and xi2 to this one and okay
so instead of having sort of having a
greedy straight greedy algorithm what
we're doing is the following we are
assigning the item to a buyer so the
greedy algorithm was a sign assigned the
item to a buyer that maximizes bij as
long as that buyer has still his budget
here we're using X I to discount bij and
we're maximizing so we sell the item to
the buyer that maximizes this expression
bij discounted by 1 minus X I and the
algorithm is is the following this and
the value of x I is updated by by this
multiplicative update and when the buyer
exhausts his budget X I is going to be
equal to 1 so we're not going to sell
him any any any item the proof of this
algorithm I won't go through the details
is very similar to what to what we have
seen the only the only issue is that we
have to assist with the last item and so
the last item allocated to a buyer and
with that last item we may exceed the
budget of the of the buyers so we have
to for the analysis we have to give up
on the revenue from that last
last item so the competitive we go yeah
so the competitive factor depends on big
R which is the ratio between an
individual bid and the budget and we
have to make we're going to the
proximity competitive factor is 1 minus
1 over e which is of course an
improvement over the factor of one-half
however we need the assumption of small
small bits and it's an interval
interesting open problem getting this
one minus 1 over e competitive factor
with without the assumption of small of
small bids no no so we can the greedy
algorithm always guarantees you a factor
of one-half and just getting above not
even 1 minus 1 over e but just getting
web of one half that's that's very
interesting no we don't have any lower
bound and in fact yeah no I meant
between one half and one minus one over
he sure and so a special a special case
going with your question when Muhammad
and a special case of this problem is
online matching in online matching we
want we have we have a bipartite think
of the same model we have a bipartite
graph one side is fixed and the other
side appears online and we want to
maximize the cardinality of the matching
that we're generating online so if we
rephrase restate this question in the
language of the ad auctions problem the
budget of every buyer is
one and each bid is also equal to one as
we will see for this special case here
we don't of within this online matching
problem we don't have the large bids the
small bits assumption but we can still
get the 1 minus 1 over e so the open
question is really in the in the middle
area where let's say some of the bids
are if the budget is one some of the
bids are half one-fourth and and so on
if all of them are one as a matching
then we will see that we can get 1 minus
1 over e with all budgets are one and
all these other ones yeah yeah exactly
yeah there's no leftover the right so
you needed this small bit assumption
because you because I because of the
waste at the at the end we okay either
either okay sure but there's material
but there's no reason to think to
believe that there's that you cannot go
above one half without their the small
bits assumption this this is this is all
I'm saying okay it's still okay you're
telling me that this is an easy special
case right online matching it's like
there's no way steel so okay it makes
life easier right it's actually this
this problem was looked online matching
was looked at long ago by Corp for an
inverse Ronnie 1990 and they they
suggest the online matching problem and
they suggested the following algorithm
so as as in ad auctions greedy algorithm
or any non lazy algorithm which means
that if you can match do it you're going
to get too competitive factor of
one-half so the question is can you go
and deterministic alee this is best
possible question is is there a
randomized algorithm that goes above
above one half
and here's a very simple algorithm you
pick in advance a random permutation
over the offline side over the fixed
side of the bipartite graph and you did
only once this once you have this random
permutation you run the greedy algorithm
with respect to it and you match and
that defines the priorities between the
the vertices on the fixed side and and
your sign according according to that in
an expectation this algorithm algorithm
turns out to have the competitive
competitive factor is 1 minus 1 over e
what is the relation between between
this randomized algorithm and online
online primal dual so we can go to so
let's look at the primal in the dual
firm formulation of matching now bij is
that we saw before bi j is equal to 1 in
B of I is equal to 1 so we just get this
is these are the matching constraints
and this is these are the covering
constraints so for every edge i J I is
the fixed side in J's the online site X
of I plus Z of jay is needs to be bigger
bigger than one so if we take the
algorithm from the ad auctions problem
then we can interpret it interpret it as
a water-level algorithm so y IJ this is
the water and that determines the value
X X of I and in practice what this
algorithm is doing is the following each
buyer that's the fixed side has a water
tube which is initially empty
when an item comes in it just starts
filling up the two of the tubes of his
neighbor's and it has water feeling
meaning meaning that only he he fills at
any point of time the item fills up the
water tubes which are at minimum level
and of course as the item starts filling
up the water tubes more and more perhaps
more and more tubes join the game as the
water level of the minimum tubes reaches
those those guys so this is this is the
interpretation of the fractional
fractional algorithm and this gives a
fractional matching of 1 minus 1 over e
but how do you make this algorithm into
a randomized integral algorithm that's a
very interesting question that it's not
it's not clear because if you try to do
some kind of randomized randomized
rounding with some probability which is
not negligible you will go above the
budget which is one in this case and
that will incur further loss and
remember any way we can get one half
so how do you do it even how do you do
it offline I mean even offline how do
you take how do you transform a
fractional matching into an integral one
the way I know is just write it as a
convict some of fret of integral
integral matchings so in very
interesting work of nickel Devon or
Bobby Kleinberg and Kemal jang from 2013
they suggested the right a randomized
primal-dual algorithm so let me give you
22 views of this of this algorithm which
are actually equivalent so that were
there is the following and we have these
empty water tubes and each each buyer
pics uniformly at random and number why
I between 0 and 1 ok now when when a new
item arrives so let's take first the
view of the kvv algorithm we can think
of these values as determining a random
permutation they determine priorities
between the buyers and now when an item
J arrives he just picks the for every
neighbor the free neighbor which
minimizes the value why I this is same
as picking a random permutation another
view is through water level so each item
J has let's say an infinite amount of
water and he just starts filling up the
water tubes of his neighbors as before
he oh he always fills up the water tubes
which are at minimum once a buyer
reaches the threshold of why I he is
matched to this to this item and it's
not hard to show that actually these two
algorithms are completely are equivalent
okay let's see now the analysis so the
idea is the following and when we have
an item J which is matched to buy your
eye we're going to set the primal
variables so X I is going to be equal to
this value e to the power of this random
variable Y I / e minus 1 and Z J is e
minus e to the Y I / e minus 1 now where
do where do these values come from so
you can think of it as so it's actually
the derivative if we look at the
assignment of X I and the fractional
algorithm what we're doing what we're
assigning here is the derivative of that
assignment of that the derivative when
sigma y IJ equals y equals y I so there
the fractional algorithm the assignment
is the integral over these derivatives
so it's and it's an expected value here
we're picking the here we're picking
this value why I and giving that what if
if we succeed in assigning we're giving
this that this the value of the
derivative for why I so it's it's not a
one-to-one correspondence but this is
more like to think about it as the
intuition where these assignments come
from otherwise if an item is unmatched
or or this should be or a buyer is
unmatched then x and z are set set to
zero and it's not hard to show that the
ratio of growth between x and z sorry
between the primal and the duel is e / e
/ e minus one as we would have liked it
to be the only issue is feasibility and
here it's really interesting you don't
have feasibility you have feasibility in
expectation and what they show the
vanora Kleinberg and jane is that with
this assignment for every for every i J
only in expectation X I + Z J is bigger
than or equal to 2 to 1 and now why is
this enough for proving the performance
well let's look at a particular pair
pidi which is generated by the algorithm
listen to and this is going to happen
with some probability Q I let's look
let's look at a primal solution which is
this convex some the average of these
primal solutions so it's going to be p i
multiplied by x qi now by the Bob lemma
peas a feasible solution of expected
size of the matching is just the value
of the dual solution x qi what we are
interested in is the ratio between the
optimal solution in the expectation of
the cardinality of the matching
expectation of value of the
II when we expand this by definition
this is equal to these these two the
ratio is equal to the ratio between
these two terms just by definition and
this is upper bounded by the maximum of
value of P I / value of di q I just
cancels out and we've we've seen in the
previous slide that this ratio
independently of feasibility is upper
bounded by y over a minus 1 so we got
that the competitive factor of this
algorithm is is 1 minus 1 over e this is
a very this is a very neat idea it's
extendable to having weight now okay now
to wait some vertices so now instead of
having just a cardinality matching we
can ask what happens with waited waited
matching so which is how our weights
defined one way one special cases when
the weight of an edge so if we have an
edge from item J to buy your I the
weight of that edge is determined by the
weight of buyer I so all the edges
adjacent to a particular buyer are have
have have the same weight and this
technique is extendable to this to this
special case and it gets 1 minus 1 over
e what happens with arbitrary edge
weights so in general you can do you can
prove any competitive factor unless you
allow what's called free free disposal
so free disposal means that if you have
matched and I a buyer I to some item J
and now J Prime comes in and he he
offers a higher
value higher weight then J then you can
match you throw away j you lose that but
now j prime is matched to I this this
for this version the greedy
deterministic greedy guarantees a half
it's an interesting open problem going
going beyond one half one result that in
this direction is the case where the
weight of an edge is the products of the
weight of edge IJ is the product between
the weight of I and the weight of j so
for this special case if if it's a
complete bipartite graph and there's a
better than half competitive randomized
algorithm which was suggested by Charak
or head singer and un sometimes appear
didn't just appear busy sir
we give also improvement over one half
for the positively case for the bounded
degree okay matching comedy technically
I have you are you doing some kind of
but that was already in work that I had
with David Dwight who is also here we
went above that was in ec last year but
let's discuss this afterwards then the
in them the general setting the problem
is still yeah way to interpret the water
filling algorithm has some kind of
entropic projection that would be
interesting to not that I not that I
know of but would be interesting to look
into this
okay let's talk about paging and have
about 20 more minutes okay I'll quickly
go over it so I assume everybody knows
about the pager paging problem we have n
n pages and we have a cache of size k
and the requests are two pages each each
time we get we get we get a request for
page if it's in the cache we don't pay
anything otherwise we have to pay one or
some weight which is associated with
that page we have to load it into the
cache and this decision that we need to
make is which which page from the cache
are we going to evict maybe in the next
step we will be requested the next
request will be to that page that we
evicted k is the best determine
deterministically k is the best we can
do this is known that this can be
achieved since the early day this was
actually in the original paper of Slater
int origin that opened up the area of
competitive analysis randomized also log
K is a lower bound and there's a log K
algorithm for both unweighted and
weighted Al Gore at and the weighted
case we go want to go quickly
so what what is the fractional what is
the fractional model so we we can
maintain in the cash fractions of
fractions of pages as long as those if K
is the size of the cache the sum of
these fractions does not exceed does not
exceed the K and if we have a request
for a page half of it is already in the
cache we need to load the other half
that would cost us half of the weight of
the of the edge so the way to get the
log K competitive algorithm is first
develop a fractional algorithm and then
do randomized the randomized rounding
and turns out that this this is the easy
part you only lose a constant factor and
you can get this log K by using writing
it as a covering patent covering packing
framework and using a similar ideas to
what we've seen we just show you a
different way you can also write it as
the following LP so you can think so why
why PT is the fraction of PHP which is
missing from the cash at at time T PT is
the page which is requested at time T
and Z is the movement costs so if if we
change a wee look at the difference
between YP t minus 1 y and minus YP t
then ZP T is the value that we pay so we
actually pay when we leave the cash not
when we enter enter the cash and if Y
apt is the current is the current
request and so at time T if this is
bigger than 0 then we pay then we pay
infinity now we can use this we can use
this LP to get the nice a nice
fractional a nice fractional algorithm I
I'll skip the details I don't have I
don't have the time time for that but
this is interesting for the following
one one reason reason that look viewing
the problem from this angle is
interesting is that let's look at the
problem of predicting from from expert
advice so we have an expert at every
step that our algorithm has to pick an
expert once the algorithm picks an
expert you see the cost of the expert
and you pay that that cost so at the end
we want to compare the the performance
of our of of our algorithm the cost of
the experts chosen by our algorithm to
the best fixed expert in hindsight so
the best expert the performance of the
best expert of course in hindsight when
seeing the whole request sequence this
is called regret this is another
approach to to online problems use very
prominently in online learning and
machine machine learning in many in many
settings we just tell you how this is
connected to to what we've seen with
Beijing we can write so first of all one
there is no really difference here
between fractional and integral integral
would be pick one expert fractional
define a probability this Ruby
over over the experts so here's a not
very exciting LP for the expert problems
it's modeled similarly to the to the
Beijing Beijing problem where movement
cost is infinity so essentially the
optimal solution of this LP is just the
static the static best expert now when
we go to the dual problem our Alex so
the dual problem has the same by strong
duality the same optimal value but now
our now we're going to our primal dual
algorithm who is defined in terms of the
dual variables and again I'll skip the
details but I'll just tell you that it
turns out to be weighted majority in
acne in disguise and the regret bound is
proved compared compared to the dual
solution and they do so that the
algorithm of course changes go changes
the distribution over the expert but we
compare ourselves to the dual objective
function which we know is equal to the
best static expert and the known results
on regret can be recovered in this in
this way
skip rounding
okay the last topic that they want to to
talk about is dual fitting in the in the
in the online in the online setting so
we saw dual dual fitting was provided a
very simple proof for the greedy for the
offline greedy algorithm for for set
cover if you remember actually it's also
very useful for proving for proving
algorithms in the interim in the online
setting so the idea is the following we
write the problem as an LP but the
algorithm is a primal algorithm primal
is now the problem that we're interested
in it is oblivious to the LP doesn't
know anything about the LP duality is
used only for proving the performance of
the of the algorithm and we are
constructing so the dual solution is not
constructed online as we have seen so
far it is rather guest of course in
accordance with the algoron line
algorithm at the end and if we do it
correctly then we can use weak duality
as our lower bound if it's a
minimization problem we'll use it as a
lower bound if it's a maximization
problem we will use the dual solution as
as an upper bound and this is closer to
component to the analysis of online
combinatorial algorithms let me go
through quickly two examples network
design and scheduling
so an online network design we have some
let's say unweighted the unweighted
graph and we have let's focus on the
case where we have costs on the edges
and now a request let's let's let's look
at the Steiner Steiner to reversion
where we have a root and we have turrets
on the Steiner tree problem we want to
connect terminals to the route through
the cheapest tree in the online version
the terminals appear one by one and we
want to connect them to to the root
through an through a three which is not
much more bounded there the ratio
between the online tree and the optimal
Steiner tree is bounded that's the
competitive factor so this problem
actually falls into the covering packing
framework and fractionally we know how
to solve it with a logarithmic
logarithmic factor I mean it's this
problem and many more problems in this
framework and the problem the problem
here is a rounding problem how do you
round online while maintaining a tree or
maintaining the cost independent
rounding is not going to is not going to
work here okay so let's see a very
simple algorithm the analysis it was
suggested by a maza and waxman looked at
it back in 1991 and algorithm is the
simplest you can think of greedy
algorithm when a terminal shows up you
connected to the route through the
cheapest path where those edges which
you have picked in previous iterations
their cost is now
were is now zero there are many ways to
analyze this this algorithm let me show
you the approach approach through duel
through duel fitting so the idea is the
following instead of having one dual
solution we're going to have a family of
dual of dual solutions actually log n
corresponding to different connection
cost so each will have so if the
connection cost is between 2 to the I
minus 1 and 2 to the I that will define
a family of dual solutions we can assume
that we have only log and such levels
because remember we're doing this at the
end because those connection costs which
are very cheap for example less than D
max D max is the maximum connection cost
less than D max divided by 2 to the N
and their contribution to the objective
function is it most d max over 2 over 2
n multiplied by n and so it's it's
negligible anyway we have to pay d man
even opt s to pee d max so now the idea
of Google fitting is very simple if we
have so the dual solution here is a set
of balls and if if the connection cost
is between 2 to the I minus 1 and 2 to
the I then we'll have a ball of radius 2
to the I minus 2 around that terminal
what we need to prove is that all the
guys which belong to a certain layer all
the balls in a certain layer are
disjoint then they define a feasible
solution the reason for that is that if
they were not a disjoint there had an
intersection then I could have
short cut I mean I could have gotten
from the terminal to the root and a
faster through a faster route
contradicting the greedy choice of the
algorithm and since I have hvz each each
family it each radius defines a feasible
dual solution whose value is a lower
bound and opt I have log and layer so we
get a log and competitive ratio such
ideas can be used to solve more general
problems like Steiner forest in Steiner
forest there isn't a single route that
they want to connect but each step I get
a pair source sync and that yields log
square n can be improved to log n it can
also be used for analyzing online
network design in a slightly different
model where we do cost sharing so now
the cost of path is shared is equally so
each edge is equally shared by the or
equally paid by the terminals who use
that edge and using dual fitting we can
show that if we look at an online
process where terminals appear one by
one and run the greedy algorithm with
respect to this measure of cost sharing
it's different from Steiner tree that we
defined earlier we can get a log square
and competitive competitive
ratio and if a different family of
problems where this this can be applied
to is scheduling where we want to
minimize the flow time we have a set of
machines and and a bunch of jobs and we
have a matrix p IJ which tells us how
much time does it take to run job I on
machine J it's an online it's an online
problem so we don't we don't know in
advance which jobs will need to run when
a job J arrives at I'm RJ we know we
know of course p I they make P I we know
the pIJ for all machines high for that
job Jerry and we also know a weight WJ
of that job and we are allowed we're
allowed to do preemption so we can we
run jobs on several jobs on a machine
we're allowed to preempt the jobs but
we're not allowed to migrate jobs from
one machine to to another now the goal
is we want to minimize the flow time
what is the flow time of a job it's the
time that elapses between the release
time and the completion time of the of
the job and we want to minimize the sum
of the weighted flow tanks WJ is the
weight of the job which is given to us
when the job shows up
to get meaningful results in this model
in the online case we need X to provide
the algorithm with extra resources and
this means that the online algorithm can
is faster so he online algorithm and
processes 1 plus epsilon unit of a job
in one one time unit
the machines are not identical you have
a pij so p IJ is the time that running
job j on machine I and this is arbitrary
so running a job on one machine might be
much faster than running it on it also
be infinite so which means that you
cannot run in from back machine and so
we can also define the weighted flow
time as the total weight of the jobs
which are alive at time at time T so so
this is so that what would be the
fractional the fractional flow time
needed for writing an LP relaxation so
if the flavor integral flow time is just
the sum of the time units between the
release time in the completion time to
do the relaxation we let's define PJF P
is the remaining processing time of
processing of job J at time T and the
contribution the contribution of a job
to the objective function is going to be
at every time unit PJ of T divided by
the total processing time now in general
so for example in this gap between five
and 12 since we have finished two-thirds
of the job up to here in this time
window we will be the fractional
algorithm will pay only one-third x the
seven-time units now of course this is
not a very good relaxation because the
integral algorithm
has to pay let's say we finished almost
the full job up to here integral
algorithm will pay one time unit up to
here and the fractional algorithm will
pay something very very little for every
for every time unit this is why for this
relaxation we will also need this
assumption of of extra extra resources
we can write we can write an integer
program so X I JT is one if job J is
processed on I during time time T let's
see so the fractional flow time is of j
is the sum of so let see why why this is
the case so let's look at time you at
the particular cated let's say this is
one for job j on machine I at time T
this is equal to one so how how many
times did this time unit contributed
itself to the flow time so it happened
from the release time up to time T when
we did this this processing so it
contributed this value divided which
which is one in the integral case but
can be any fractional in the relaxation
/ p IJ multiplied by t minus rj the
number of times that it contributed
itself so that this is the objective
function and now we need to to finish
all all the all the jobs this is our
this is our
constraint and this is actually not not
enough this still I mean these
constraints do not we can still take a
job and split it between many machines
so to avoid and then we can do it very
quickly and this is a force against the
rules to avoid the situation we add
another term to the objective function
which is the sum of the processing time
so this is this is our LP let me just
tell you quickly quickly how dual
fitting comes in here and the algorithm
is going to be a greedy algorithm so
when a job arrives we have to decide on
which machine we're going to to run it
and we're going to dispatch the job on
the machine for which the increase in
fractional flow time is minimized in the
unweighted case we're just going to run
SRP t which is shortest remaining
processing time on each machine and
choose the one on which this increase is
minimized in the weighted case we'll
have to do it with respect to density
where density is the weight of a job /
the remaining
remaining processing time but notice
that the priorities are by our fixed
between the jobs and once one once they
arrive and this algorithm is analyzed by
through the through through dual fitting
i'll skip i'll skip the details but the
idea is to guess values for the alpha v
their dual variables or alpha and beta i
T values for them which correspond to
the to the flow to the fractional float
both to the fractional flow time and the
actual flow time of of the algorithm oh
okay i'll stop here we can restart well
maybe the time let's take the questions
offline break for lunch you come back at
one thirty